ivy
nice to see you again thank you
how's everything
it's everything it's been a while since
i've seen you
yeah
yeah
it's been a
long while too long actually so you had
a baby
yeah a beautiful baby girl i named her
eating
yeah
am i eating
and what's going on with your life
are you working the streets still
i'm not working on the street anymore
um but i have been i have been smoking a
lot
a lot what made you relapse
it's i don't know i don't know what made
me relapse i just i just
i smoked it
i just
i never i try not to think about it too
much when i i try to get sober
uh i try not to like beat myself up
about it
if i want to smoke i don't go you know i
don't sit like should i should i just do
it i just to get
the pain out of mine just to
his life just not be myself just go
ahead and do it is life just too
stressful sometimes
not even that i just i find myself
not having anything
to do when i know there's so much for me
to do i just
i just do it recreationally
i don't even get high anymore
i know i don't even get high anymore
i don't know
are you with your kids
you have two right
i have two two girls yeah i have two
girls
um
genesis and eden
genesis was adopted by her grandmother
and
eden is in
the care of a foster parent
and oh my god when i looked at her i'll
show you a picture of it it's just
my baby
my baby
i think about her all the time
and you lost her why
because you were smoking
that's what it is
and that's all it is
it's the
the addiction
yeah it's the addiction
these drugs mess up so many lies
yeah
it's self-inflicted though
most of the time it's self-inflicted i
mean you know there's no amount of
background history
that i you know i could talk about
at this age anymore to say this is why i
do it
i can't come up with any more excuses
you can't blame your parents anymore i
can't there's no more excuses there's no
more pain
there's no more you know
i wish i wish i could
i wish i could blame it on something
else
but i can't
and um every day it's harder to look in
the mirror
and you know every day it's you know
harder to just
love myself or like myself a little bit
more
um
[Music]
but
but then again that's why i do it again
i take a hit again
[Music]
my mom
um she used to say this saying
and i saw a video the other day and he
says
people who say it is what it is they're
dangerous people
because
no matter what happens it's just like
they're they've created this mindset
that's just like it is what it is
whatever you know whatever it is what it
is and that can hurt a lot of people
um
they can hurt me it hurts me as well and
i found myself saying it a lot
it is what it is it is what it
is and then a day goes by and it is what
it is and a week go by and it is what it
is
you know
and my babies are gone and it is what it
is
you know and my mom's still out there is
what it is though
i've been [ __ ] up in my head a lot
mark because
you can't accept what's not acceptable
you can't you can't
you have to draw a line
you know
i've been a quiet kid i've been a very
quiet kid all my life i've been a quiet
lady of one man with everyone
i've been quiet all my life
and i always tell myself i wish you
would just talk
just say something
you know
and when i try to speak it's like
i feel like i don't know what to say
because i don't know what i feel anymore
you know
drugs in the streets and
prostitution and
everything in the streets everything out
here that leaves us stuck it's not worth
it
it's not worth it
and the reason it's not worth it mark is
because
you get to a point where you're sitting
down one day you realize
i need this i need a car
maybe it'd be easy if i had a car
i need an apartment
you know so we go out there and we
hustle and we create this this idea in
our head therefore if i just come up
with a good one you know
if i just come up with a good one i i'll
have enough to get this
but it's just a
it's just a fantasy
because 200 isn't gonna get us through
the day
a thousand dollars isn't gonna get us
through the week
we're so far behind that there's no
amount of money anymore
you know
so every day i keep going and i keep
going but
my dreams get farther and farther and
that's why drugs isn't worth it you know
it's not worth it
so then again it is what it is i tell
myself but it is what it is you know
this is how i'm gonna die
i wish i had a stayed in school
i wished i had i did this and that this
and that
i found myself telling myself that
i'm happy my kids aren't with me
because i'm smart
i'm i'm you know i'm a good person i'm
this
i'm all of these things but
did i really want to put her through
this you know
relapse after relapse after relapse
when i had my first daughter i fed her
well you know she had toys she had this
and that all off my [ __ ] you know all
of me just catching dates in the middle
of the night
but in order for me to work i had to
leave her sleep by herself
in order for me to work i had to say sis
can you just watch it for a second i
don't know who the [ __ ] she had coming
around
you know but to me in my head i got high
and i'm upbeat and to me in my head it's
like okay i'm doing this i'm a mom i'm a
mother
so i'm thankful that
her grandmother has her
because
that's not what i wanted for my baby
you know
i grew up in a dope house
you know my mom held me in her arms
while she was cooking dope
i grew up like that
and my mom asked she goes i wonder why
you weren't a drug dealer before you
wear a prostitute
because you was around dope
that's not really a question you ask
your kid
and so
i thought about it i'm like maybe i
should sell dope
maybe that's what my mom wants me to do
life has become just this concoction of
[ __ ]
just [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
and i can't put it into perspective
i don't know what the purpose of it is
anymore
there's no purpose in this
you know
and when people say there's beauty in
this [ __ ] there's no beauty here it's
not
it's not beautiful
you can't succeed like this
and to feel good
to feel good it's only pleasure
in the quiet
for me
and my quiet is a depressing place
you know i can't take a walk in the park
and be depressed
i used to be able to take a walk and
feel good just like the air i can't know
more
because everything i've done over the
years has just
ripped me and beat me up
and it just hurt me
mark and i can't think about anything to
happen anymore
and i want my babies so bad but i don't
want them in this
i don't want them here i don't want them
with this depressed
because my mother was she was sober for
14
years but when she relapsed
killed me even more
because i finally saw the the woman that
my brothers and sisters had seen
and i hated
i hate it so much
so that makes me think maybe i should
just let my baby go you know so i got to
think about her
and a month would go by and a year went
by and i had went to visit her
and i logged on facebook
and my baby was calling her grandmother
mommy
and it killed me
my brother used to tell me she doesn't
deserve to be called mom because she
wasn't a mom
and just to hear my baby call her
grandmother mommy
i told myself wow
you lost that privilege how does that
feel
but i can talk about my pain all day and
what i've done
it's still all self-inflicted
at the age of 23 is self-inflicted
i've done nothing
but smoke
i hope that whoever watches these videos
is just
is not taking it as entertainment
but take it as something to learn from
because it doesn't matter where you come
from drugs are there
drugs are there
i started doing drugs in a laundry room
drugs are there gonna be there
it's not fun
when
the party's over
and
you still want to get high and everyone
else goes to work it's not fun
an addict is an addict
whether you do it weekly monthly
you don't want to be the one who ends up
having to do it daily
i had a good childhood
i had dreams
um
but i was raised around
women who
weren't very
dependable
emotionally mentally
um
and my grandma to this day i talk to her
almost every day she always tells me i'm
sorry evie i love you i'm sorry i didn't
do anything for you
she spent 30 years in her mother's
garage
she couldn't leave her mother
so depression was all i was around
you know sad women
i grew up in the in the rooms of cocaine
anonymous i knew the serenity prayer
before i was six years old
but look at me now you know
there's nothing in the world
that i would give
up just to change that moment i still
needed love
no matter how many stories i'd heard
about the streets and having to deal
with the the the addiction there's
nothing i i still did it
i still did it
i still did it
it's only gonna get harder
to
accept
yourself every day when you become
addicted
to something so potent
it only gets harder
um
i want to get better for my babies
but every time i try to get up in the
morning
say maybe i should go visit her
i'm scared
because the guilt
and the shame
is so strong
there's nothing out here worth it where
it's worth losing your life
okay you
know um
so i'm still working on being me
and learning me
because
starting to do drugs at a certain age
it's like
becoming addicted to something and
wanting something at that young it's
like
me and who i am
is out of the picture
but i want it so bad i want to know who
i am
i want to know what ivy likes
i want to know ivy loves
i just started telling my the people
around me not my friends
call me by my government name because i
want to hear it again
you know
um
but they can't do it
so i would start responding to my street
name
and it would upset people why do you
want to be
like why are you trying to do something
because that's me that's what i was
named
and i'd appreciate it if you caught me
by my first day
i'm trying to hold on to anything that
makes me feel real again human
anything
oh yeah
i still have girls who call me
you know
just to talk to me and see how my i'm
doing
and um
i'm embarrassed
it's hard to go in
in
family settings or
that's different settings other than
where where i am because
you feel it
you know you feel the rape
and you feel the abuse
and you feel the anger
and you feel what people have called you
and done to you over the years when
you're around
a brighter
setting
and
it's not a good feeling
i realize that
you know i'm somebody only when i'm
around people who haven't went the route
that i've went
and that sucks
i like being here
do you ever get a chance to talk about
this stuff with anyone
or what
for
what you know
i can have conversations about god and
you know doing good and going to school
and but then it's like pass me the pipe
for what
i'm not saying people that are out here
in the streets are just ugly people we
we need love too
but
at a certain point
we gotta
be left
where we are because
we become some someone in something
unsuitable
for a public nature because
you know
what value are we to our kids
what value are we to a workplace
when we gotta sneak in the bathroom just
to go get high
or you know
i feel so adorable
unnatural
you know what do you do
what else i was reading about how
they had made the tiny houses for the
people trying to get them off the
streets
and they offered my mom one
and she rejected it
because when she went inside it was just
like so
hideous
and i said i knew it i knew it i had
said i see you're gonna
give these people that need help help
but it's not like you can just give us a
house and a car and say okay now you
have what we have so go ahead and be you
know be the best you can be
it doesn't work that way
you know
because not only
do we need the materials we also need
the love
we need the mental health
and a lot of us are too far gone
that we couldn't create a home
anymore
how
how
does that happen
oh
so it's just like
it it's it's painful
you know
if you can just live a life
there's no amount of drugs creating they
can't give you a better happiness than
to be able to say you take care of your
family
you know
it feels
i know it feels way better
this is not needed
you know it's not a necessity until
you're addicted
have fun
without
have fun without it because we're
addicted you can't fun
you didn't hire getting drunk anymore
there's no fun
oh my goodness
i stopped calling you because i'm just
like i don't want to be that [ __ ]
that's just like mark i need this and i
need that and i need this because i know
i need it and even if he was to give it
to me i'ma still need it
you know
and um
you've never been one of those i i mean
for what
um
this means a lot to me what you do
because
depression
is a [ __ ]
whether you're addicted to drugs or not
it's really hard
but imagine being addicted to drugs and
depressed
you know
to help someone in that kind of state is
is a tricky situation
because
money don't last too long
in our hands you know
i don't even know my daughter's shoe
size anymore i don't even know
if i was to go buy a pair of shoes uh
because i'm too busy getting high
this is not
a situation
that
money can
help
or cure
you know
it becomes embedded
and
it's not pretty
so it's not the love it's not the money
that i appreciate it's but it's the love
it's the care just to care
that you give
and
that alone to me is so beautiful because
my mother wasn't very affectionate
you know
first time i tried to kill myself
she just walked in and she looks and she
backs away and she walked away
you know
that's not
the reaction i was expecting or i was
hoping for
it's not over for me
it's not over i'm not dead yet
so the love is always something i craved
just a love that naturally flows
you know there's nothing you can give me
except for love because that one is so
bad
uh
i salute all the women that are in the
game
and that have created a foundation in
the game and
got to where they wanted to be
starting with the game
but don't make it so beautiful
you know
that you know the game is this and that
because life is real life
and you got babies that's out here just
hoping to be that beautiful hoe
you know
and and when i was 19 i knocked the 16
i'm not the 15 year old not knowing she
was 15.
until this day she calls me she says i
love you
you know
that doesn't feel good to me no more
you know to bring another woman back to
a pen but don't feel good to me no more
it's not fulfilling
because nowadays it's different there's
no success
there's you know there's no stability in
this no more i wouldn't want nobody to
see this [ __ ]
you know
you got this glamorous this beautiful
image of what you know a hoe and a pimp
should be and you know what life in the
street selling drugs is and i'm you know
i sell drugs now i'm missing that hey i
salute the ones who thought that you
know you made it
but you gotta be
aware that
it's not really
beautiful
you know it's such a stage to dream
know
it's a fantasy
these are [ __ ] up people
you know
sex is an addiction too
exercise is an addiction too
you know eating is an addiction too
that is is killing the youth
it's killing our babies
and i hope that my baby i have to see it
one day
um
and that's why i don't go see my kids
because
what have i learned
in the game you know
every pimp you meet out there is it
gonna be
good for you
that [ __ ] is not worth it
i can't teach my baby how to hoe i gotta
teach you how to be a woman
i can't just tell my baby it is what it
is it's not
but that's the only thing i wanted to
get i was taught in the game
you do it you get through it
you don't gotta be like that
you don't gotta be like that
i said i'm turning 23
23.
that's young but
i thought i just started doing drugs
yesterday i'm like oh god
my eyes are dark underneath it's like
ugh my weight
i don't like shopping no more i'm like
i'm 23. i should love this shop
i can't find nothing that fits me
you know
i try every day to make sure i tell
myself that i love myself
but to anyone who has had drugs around
them and wanted to try it out it's not
worth it
because you just might be that one that
gets addicted
you just might be that one and it's not
a beautiful place anymore
you know
it's not
find something you love to do
even if you don't you try something
and if it's uncomfortable you try
something else
if you don't like that you try something
else
because if
a 50 year old can try
all different kind of drugs for 50 years
you can try tons
and tons of different hobbies there's
every there's so much to do
please
don't do this this is not it
you know
there's so much to do
there's no limit to
anything you can do in this world
this is crazy these buildings they can
make
and they're not tumbling
that's crazy
it's it's insane
okay
you're seeing things more clearly now
i always knew it
i just
i don't apply it you're getting older
and
wiser yeah
hopefully
but it means nothing if i don't use it
anything you know how to do
should be used as a gift
don't hold it
give it away
not your body
give it away if you know how to do
something
show someone else
because the person sitting next to you
might be depressed and they don't know
what to do
be that person that can say hey i know
how to do this
and when you're 40 and 50 years old you
can say i learned how to do that i know
how to do that
i also learned how to do that i know how
to do that
i don't want to be 60. say i'm just not
a hoe
i
[Music]
don't just live life be life
be life
give life
that's what i want to do i want to give
life
i want to be life
you know
it's not over for me
it's not over i'm not dead yet
thank you mark
you're amazing thank you such a great
talk
you got to do one of these every few
months
it's inspiring to all the other girls
out there
nobody talks like that
you